[Music]
breaking news this monday night
america's longest war is over i'm here
to announce the completion of our
withdrawal from afghanistan the
international pressure on the taliban to
let afghans escape safely
the chaos of hurricane ida i've seen
damage but not like this where the storm
is heading next greenhouse gas emission
goals how canada's target compares to
other countries and how the
conservatives plan stacks up plus game
changer china's new rules for playing
video games online
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with breaking news out of
afghanistan where it is august 31st
after 20 years america's longest war is
now over the u.s military has completed
its withdrawal afghanistan is officially
in the hands of the taliban the pentagon
says the final u.s evacuation flight
left kabul one minute before midnight
local time the american ambassador was
among those on board
tonight's withdrawal signifies both the
end of the military component of the
evacuation but also the end of the
nearly 20-year mission that began in
afghanistan shortly after september 11
2001.
more than 123 000 people
have been safely flown out of
afghanistan we believe there are still a
small number of americans
under 200
and likely closer to 100
who remain in afghanistan and want to
leave
we're trying to determine exactly how
many
this video was taken tonight on the
streets of kabul there are reports
celebratory gunfire could be heard
across the city
earlier in the day a series of military
flights took off from kabul's airport as
u.s forces scrambled to wrap up their
withdrawal thousands of vulnerable
afghans including those who helped the
canadian military have been left behind
redmond shannon has tonight's top story
on the historic american withdrawal and
the chaos left behind
just hours before the u.s departure from
afghanistan was complete another
airstrike against the so-called islamic
state
this time on a car that had fired
rockets toward kabul airport
the pentagon says sunday's strike killed
two militants but reports say 10
civilians died in the explosion
including six children
nobody
wants to see innocent life taken
we take it very very seriously further
bloodshed will not help the west's
efforts to convince the taliban to
cooperate in evacuations after tuesday's
deadline western foreign ministers met
to discuss just how that will be done
prime minister justin trudeau said
canada will pressure the taliban to get
everyone out this is something we will
continue to do into the coming months
alongside our allies and our partners
on monday the globe and mail reported
that ukrainian special forces went into
kabul friday to escort 19 canada-bound
afghans to the airport but with all
foreign troops now gone one former
canadian interpreter told global news
all he can do is pray
we are here about
even more than 100 families
in this area
and
that everyone
know about that that we are in here
so we hope they will not say anything to
us and we will not do anything to us in
new york the united nations security
council passed a resolution to allow
safe passage from afghanistan the turf
outside the airport the gates are run by
the taliban so they will select who gets
to get through security expert steven
seiderman says the taliban won't want to
let other countries decide who gets to
leave we're not going to be able to get
out of the country everybody who wants
to leave we might see a large number of
refugees fleeing afghanistan and ending
up in camps on pakistan as two decades
of nato's power and influence in
afghanistan now comes to an end redmond
shannon global news london
[Music]
this is a view from a coast guard
helicopter of the damage left by
hurricane ida home after home torn to
shreds the full scope of the disaster is
still being assessed
ida came ashore sunday south of new
orleans the storm's relentless rainfall
swamped communities while wicked winds
ripped across the state storms usually
lose strength after moving over land
that wasn't the case with ida after it
came ashore it stays as a category four
storm for six hours the storm knocked
out power to more than a million homes
and businesses at least one person was
killed and officials fear that number
will rise
ida is now a tropical depression turning
through the southern states as jennifer
johnson reports louisiana and its
neighbors are facing a long road to
recovery from another historic storm
that proof is coming holy
with winds hitting over 241 kilometers
per hour hurricane ida was one of the
most powerful storms to ever hit the u.s
it came in as a category 4 hurricane but
stayed at that level for hours almost
everywhere you look there is destruction
obviously hurricane ida
packed a very powerful punch she came in
and did everything that was advertised
unfortunately
thousands of homes and businesses are
destroyed this man thankful his family
was not killed by a falling tree it's a
blessing that it fell
to the side instead of straight down the
middle
because that's where the bedrooms are
hospitals already packed with copin 19
patients are operating on generators
trees and power lines are down hundreds
of roads unpassable i've seen damage but
not like this there are major power
outages and people are without water in
louisiana thousands too in mississippi
meaning no air conditioning in the
august heat
i think people should be prepared for
several weeks before the full power
restoration comes on you know and we're
not going to be able to tell you exactly
where it's going to come on first
whatever you need president joe biden
held a virtual meeting with the head of
the federal emergency management agency
and the governors of the states affected
by ida pledging billions in aid and help
more than 5 000 members of your national
guard have been activated from louisiana
mississippi
alabama and texas to support search and
rescue and recovery efforts ida roared
through louisiana exactly 16 years to
the day that hurricane katrina all but
destroyed new orleans and surrounding
communities killing over 1800 people
since then 14 billion dollars have been
spent on levees and floodgates which
held up well it was pretty intense
a lot of wicked winds
luckily no flooding that's the main
difference between this storm and
katrina cleanup and recovery efforts
will take months and billions of dollars
but ida isn't done yet her powerful
winds are threatening tornadoes heavy
rains and flash flooding in tennessee
kentucky and the mid-atlantic states as
she charges north
jennifer johnson global news washington
the people of louisiana have faced their
share of extreme weather five named
storms pummeled the state last year and
the memories of katrina are still fresh
even though the dangers of riding out a
hurricane like ida are well known as
mike armstrong explains not everyone got
out of its way
it may be a lesson you can only learn by
living through a hurricane you can try
to ride it out but you might end up
regretting it last night was rough this
woman says water started creeping under
her door and then got higher and higher
ankles knees
almost chest levels so we just put the
dogs on the counters
and then we climbed into the attic
if you're watching this or if you see
this
please pray for us while some areas made
it through without too much damage
others took it on the chin the roof of
this building was pulled off with the
resident inside he posted a video that
shows a look of disbelief
there were those who tried to get out
but it appears too late several people
were rescued on this street by an
off-duty member of the italian navy
it's okay
now the wind may be done but in some
areas water is still a problem
surveillance cameras at a fire station
show how quickly the water rose in just
one hour a day later some communities
are still flooded residents are having
to be rescued somebody always tells me
some days you live in the water some
days the water lives on you it was bad
it was the worst thing ever it was the
worst thing ever i got my baby out
though i wasn't gonna stop trying to get
my baby out
yeah she all right safe ass out
while in some areas people are still
being moved out in others evacuees want
to go back
being told for now to hold off and
especially not to go sightseeing
like armstrong global news
to the canadian federal election the
liberal party is pushing its climate
agenda promising to protect canada's big
lakes and rivers leader justin trudeau
is trying to paint his party as the
environmental choice but critics say his
track record tells a different story
david aiken is traveling with the
liberal campaign david
well robin canada has about twenty
percent of the world's fresh water but
only about seven percent of the world's
renewable fresh water the kind of water
that is replenished by a rainfall and
that's why scientists say canada needs
to be smart about water use and water
management even though we have so much
of this stuff canada has a
responsibility to be a world leader
and invest in freshwater research the
liberals say that if re-elected they'll
spend a hundred million dollars a year
for each of the next 10 years to protect
large lakes and river systems they'll
also overhaul a lot of the federal rules
around protecting water quality and
watersheds including completing the
creation of a new national agency the
canada water agency with monday's
announcement on clean water and sundays
on new rules for the oil and gas sector
trudeau is trying to argue that the
liberal party has been and will be
canada's greenest government ever there
has never been a government as ambitious
as this one on climate change but of
course as the ndp were quick to point
out sunday canada's emissions have been
rising faster than any of its g7 peers
and of course the trudeau government
well
it bought an oil pipeline robin
david aiken in quebec thanks david
speaking of pipelines the year after the
northern gateway pipeline project was
shelved by the liberals the
conservatives are saying they'd support
its revival the idea was to pipe oil
from alberta's oil sands to bc's coast
leader aaron o'toole believes it will
help indigenous communities with
economic opportunities but as michael
couture reports some first nations
groups challenged the project which saw
its approval overturned
politics and puppies are a perfect
pairing when you're being dogged by
other issues on the campaign trail aaron
o'toole was talking about animal welfare
at this rescue center while trying to
pivot away from pipelines the northern
gateway is a
gazillion
important sunday night on a grazio
canada interview with all federal
leaders o'toole said he is in favor of
resurrecting the northern gateway
pipeline a project that was shelved in
2016 by the liberals after a federal
court of appeal ruled the government
didn't sufficiently consult indigenous
communities what we have to do is get
trans mountain built
and try and make sure that we we get
access for our resources which are
leaders in environmental and social
governance
o'toole believes it would create
economic benefits for indigenous
communities along the route that signed
economic partnerships
there was plenty of opposition to it
especially in vote rich bc where the
conservatives are hoping to win more
seats and where environmentalists point
out the effects of climate change are
being felt daily more billions spent on
fossil fuel infrastructure will result
in climate breakdown and will undermine
all our jobs the entire economy in
canada and in bc o'toole's position on
new pipelines is contrary to the
international energy agency's report
saying if countries like canada want to
achieve net zero emissions by the year
2050 no new fossil fuel projects should
be built as we see a
lower carbon future we should make sure
that democratic countries use canadian
resources not resources from saudi
arabia or venezuela or russia expect the
liberals ndp and greens to zero in on
o'toole's position on another pipeline
as those parties attempt to make the
environment a key issue of this campaign
robin mike look at her in vaughan
ontario thanks mike
the conservatives are gaining ground in
the polls and o'toole faces a growing
chance of becoming the next prime
minister but he's being pressed on the
climate crisis as eric sorensen reports
this issue is one area where there are
clear differences among the parties
for months conservative leader aaron
o'toole pledged to meet canada's paris
targets to cut greenhouse gas emissions
on our plan the detained news objective
de paris last night he was more explicit
in a french language interview making
clear he'll stick to the harper
government commitments made six years
ago not the new higher pledge made by
the trudeau government
30 said o'toole which was the harper
target that would roll back ottawa's
current commitments further behind other
western nations one research group says
the uk has the most aggressive targets
pledging to cut emissions 63 below 2005
levels by 2030. the biden administration
has set a new u.s goal of 50 to 52
percent lower the eu is similar canada's
commitment is now 40 to 45 percent under
the trudeau government the conservative
party is sticking to emission cuts that
are 30 percent below 2005 levels i want
us to make sure we meet our commitments
other countries are a little tardy on
their commitments as well justin trudeau
says it comes down to a choice going
back to the harper approach on the
environment under mr o'toole
or continuing to be ambitious one
climate advocate says the liberal
targets aren't good enough but the
conservative she says would weaken them
even further just before nations gather
at the next u.n climate summit this fall
raising ambition is really at the core
of the paris agreement
weakening at target that has already
been set would be a diplomatic disaster
and a failure to recognize that canada
has a large responsibility and capacity
to act liberals want to show the stark
contrast one liberal mp points to
several conservative candidates who
downplay the science of human-caused
climate change trudeau has also pledged
to regulate oil and gas with new
five-year emissions reduction targets
o'toole suggests trudeau's promises are
not credible we have to have a plan to
get there mr trudeau says nice things
and then doesn't deliver the new
democrats have emissions targets steeper
than the liberals and much more so than
the conservatives but they are running
third in the polls as voters consider
which party and climate policies they'll
support eric sorensen global news
toronto
the conservative party has confirmed it
will not run a candidate in nova
scotia's dartmouth coal harbor riding
conservative candidate troy myers was
asked to step aside after being accused
of sexually assaulting a woman at a work
conference in 2019.
we need to make sure that we have a
slate of candidates that are here to
serve the country and that we show
support for victims and zero tolerance
the deadline to get a party endorsed
candidate has passed and the
conservatives say it will not be
represented well global national is
gearing up to go on the road again
tomorrow donna freezen will report from
calgary on what could be in store for
alberta this time around and she joins
us with more hi donna
hi robin i am in alberta this week
talking about the federal election
campaign the liberals were shut out of
alberta and saskatchewan in the last
election will it be the same this time
around we're going to talk about the
issue of a just transition what it means
to transition from oil and gas to green
energy we're going to take you to the
pito glacier in banff it's retreating at
an unprecedented pace and i'll talk to
the outgoing mayor of calgary about his
11 years in office and how he feels
about politics now and about the future
of alberta that's all coming up tomorrow
all right looking forward to it thanks
donna the alberta government has
announced it will start rolling out
third doses of coven 19 vaccines for
eligible residents the booster will be
available for seniors living in
congregate care facilities and
immunocompromised albertans the province
also says mrna doses will be made
available to albertans traveling to
countries that don't accept astrazeneca
or mixed doses quebec announced it will
also provide a third dose for people who
are immunocompromised or on dialysis for
now the province is not recommending the
booster for long-term care patients
the race to control a raging inferno
coming up the fears of where
california's destructive fire is headed
next
russian cosmonauts say they have found
new cracks on the aging international
space station they appear to be
superficial but the fissures could widen
over time it's the latest setback for
the iss in july it was knocked off
position after a new module accidentally
fired its thrusters last month an air
leak was reported which caused the air
pressure to drop in living quarters
now to california where fire crews are
scrambling to get control of a massive
wildfire near lake tahoe officials say
despite best efforts over the weekend
the so-called colder fire has picked up
steam and it's racing toward the popular
resort area more mandatory evacuation
orders are in effect since the calder
fire started about two weeks ago roughly
500 homes had been destroyed
we're getting a better sense of just how
devastating this year's drought is for
wheat farmers in western canada a new
report from statistics canada estimates
this year's wheat harvest will be about
22.9 million tons that's down 35 percent
from last year and it's the lowest in 14
years canola farmers have also been hit
hard this year's yield is set to drop by
24
compared to last year
still ahead the ndp's plan to make the
ultra rich pay
the ndp is starting week three of the
campaign targeting the ultra rich leader
jagmeet singh called out previous
governments for giving the super wealthy
what he calls a free ride abigail beeman
is following the ndp campaign abigail
robin the ndp leader started the day in
a liberal stronghold ottawa riding
talking about his plan to tax the ultra
rich jagmeet singh says a new democrat
government would invest 100 million
dollars in the canada revenue agency to
step up enforcement and close loopholes
the ndp leader believes that could bring
in 25 billion dollars in revenue a big
and perhaps questionable number based on
a parliamentary budget officer's report
about how much is lost annually in
revenue every year due to tax avoidance
but tackling tax loopholes and taxing
the so-called ultra-rich is a
long-standing ndp trope i asked the
leader what's different now from 2019
when those promises did not get him
elected we just saw a bunch of
billionaires go to space while people
went through the worst economic crisis
of their lives
people are pretty frustrated with that
chuck mead singh heads west to vancouver
island where the party thinks they have
a good shot to unseat one of only two
sitting green mps paul manley in a
former ndp riding as the greens battle
internal turmoil robin all right thanks
abigail up next a young canadian makes
big waves in the paralympic pool
[Music]
parents know how difficult it can be to
limit video games for kids well in china
the government is doing it beijing is
banning minors from playing online games
for more than three hours a week kids
will only be allowed to play between
eight and nine pm on fridays weekends
and holidays video game addiction has
been compared to drug use in china
in tokyo another young canadian swimmer
is taking home hardware from the
paralympics new brunswick's 18 year old
danielle dorr swam to second in the
women's 100 meter backstroke s7 she even
set a new personal best clocking in at
one minute and 21.91 seconds this is her
first paralympic medal
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is hogs hogsback falls on the
rideau river in ottawa please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and be sure to
tune in tomorrow when donna friesen will
broadcast from calgary until then have a
great night
[Music]